[MUSIC PLAYING]
WILLIAM JONES: SPIDER's a
millimeter-wave polarimeter.
It's designed to
image the polarization
that's in the microwave
background radiation.
The ultimate goal of SPIDER
is to see to what extent
we can identify a very
characteristic feature
in that polarization,
that's expected
to have come from
the early stages
of the evolutionary
growth of our universe.
SASHA RAHLIN: SPIDER
will, basically,
map out a portion of the sky.
And we're going to map out the
intensity and the polarization
of the light that we
can see from the sky.
And that'll be a combination
of primordial radiation--
so, light that has been
traveling basically
since the Big Bang, since the
beginning of the universe.
And also, intensity
from the galaxy.
So we have to
disentangle those two,
and we'll map out what that
part of the sky looks like.
And we'll be able to
model it, and determine
the parameters that kind of
govern what the universe was
like, at the very beginning
WILLIAM JONES: The schedule
for a balloon launch
like this is,
essentially, that you
need to qualify for a
long-duration balloon flight
the summer prior to a
launch-- within a few weeks
of Christmas.
Normally, the process--
and what we did last year--
was that you would
deploy your instrument
to the CSBF facility
in Palestine, Texas.
You would integrate
the payload there.
And you would test it with
all of the flight systems that
are provided by NASA.
And once you've
demonstrated that they all
play well together,
then you ship directly
from that facility in
Texas to Antarctica.
We went through that
process last year,
but then, of course,
the government shutdown
resulted in the cancellation
of all the flights.
Because we did it last year,
we're staying here this year.
But it's the same schedule.
That is, we'll integrate it
all in the high bay, here.
The team will meet the
payload and all the equipment
in Antarctica.
About the second
week of October,
the first groups
will leave from here.
And then you really have
the month of November,
and the first three weeks
of December to set up a lab,
build the experiment, calibrate
it, make sure it's all working,
and get it ready for launch.
STEVE BENTON: SPIDER's awesome.
It's studying,
like, the Big Bang.
It's almost
unbelievable that we can
test what SPIDER wants to test.
I get to do that, while building
a really cool robot to make
that happen.
And then I fly it in the
stratosphere from Antarctica.
I get to do this
really cool thing,
in this really awesome way.
And it's great.
SASHA RAHLIN: As
a scientist, these
are the kinds of questions
you really want answers to,
right-- the big questions about
how did the universe, you know,
why are we here, to some extent.
SPIDER is a really cool
instrument to do that with.
You know, ballooning in
general is really cool.
It's really fun, as
a young scientist,
to get involved with that
kind of a instrument.
These kinds of
projects naturally
lead to satellite instruments,
and larger-scale science.
So it's a really good
jumping-off point,
as a graduate student,
to get involved
with this kind of a project.
[MUSIC PLAYING]